I identify more as a Swifty than I do as
a comedian or a woman or anything me too
oh yeah my fiance is a huge Swifty as
well we got tickets to one of the shows
and now she's trying to get tickets for
another show because she's like I need
to go to multiple of these things to
support the different openers I just
bought tickets yesterday you know six
thousand dollars for three tickets I'm
not someone who spends a lot but this is
like oh I can spend this insane amount
of money that would be like a trip to
Europe or the Middle East we don't know
really
um well I think if you're Jewish you can
go to Israel for free one time right oh
that's true yeah oh I wish there was a
Birthright for Taylor Swift that would
be awesome oh [ __ ] we gotta start that
like if you're like a a blonde white
girl who grew up on a Christmas tree
farm you get you get to go to free are
you a Swifty yeah my my uncle was yeah
that's right you're only supposed to
give your mother one yeah all right yeah
right yeah dude yeah you don't count you
do not count